there's a clip that went super viral of
you doing your podcast and someone
showed up with a weapon
can you walk us through what that was
like for you one night you know i'm just
hanging out everybody's smoking chilling
there's probably five or six dudes there
in the back of the bike shop we ordered
some postmates my guy goes outside and
grabs it and as he's opening the door
this dude sneaks in who's kind of hiding
in the corner back there and he runs
towards me with his gun and starts
pointing my head and like you see in the
clip that i'm kind of like covering up
and i go i made this like weird noise
like
nervous action or what but the thing you
can't see on camera that was kind of
trippy is that my guy got his gun out
pointed at the dude's head so by the
time i see this dude running at me i'm
also thinking like oh my god this dude's
about to get murdered right in front of
me right now and somehow the guy did not
pull the trigger and we beat the [ __ ]
out of the guy and then the gun ended up
being fake we called the cops cops like
didn't even want to come why did the
cops not want to come i guess just
because melrose is a [ __ ]
free-for-all